حسنًا ، إحدى النقاط المهمة من
نتيجة 19 السرية الإيجابية للرئيس ترامب هي أنها وحدت
العديد من القادة في جميع أنحاء العالم التي
سمعناها من
رئيس وزراء إسرائيل بنيامين نتنياهو يقول
إن ملايين
الإسرائيليين هو وزوجته سارة
يتمنون للرئيس والأول  سيدة
الشفاء العاجل الشفاء العاجل
ما سمعناه من
رئيس تركيا هو ما سمعناه من
رئيس كوريا الجنوبية مون جاي إن
كما سمعناه من جنرال
الناتو
أه أتمنى للرئيس والى
السيدة الأولى ، الشفاء السريع
الذي كان حقًا نوعًا من
الرسالة الموحدة الموحدة ، لقد
ذهب الرئيس بوتين
خطوة أخرى إلى الأمام ،
حيث أرسل برقية إلى الرئيس ترامب
تخبره أن حيويته
بأن تفاؤله كانت أشياء
ستساعده على التعافي وتسريعه.
في طريق العودة إلى صحة جيدة ، أرسل
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ، بوريس جونسون ،
تمنياته إلى
الرئيس للسيدة الأولى ، متمنياً لهم
الشفاء العاجل.  بالطبع يعرف نفسه كيف
يكون الأمر عندما قضى
أكثر من أسبوع في المستشفى في وقت سابق من هذا العام ، حيث قضى أكثر من أسبوع في المستشفى في وقت سابق من هذا
العام ، واستغرق الأمر
عدة أسابيع للتعافي ، لذا كانت لحظة نادرة
من الوحدة
بين زعماء العالم الذين أرسلوا
دعمهم للرئيس ترامب
والرئيس.  السيدة الأولى نيك روبرتسون CNN
لندن